[Music]
1742 okay so we're really moving up in
the ranks and a french
you guys know those of you who've been
around for
a while which line i like to play
against the french
name it in peter's honor
so i play e5 it's traditionally called
the steinitz variation and in this
position who can tell me what move
i am a big fan of knight f3 yeah knight
f3
okay so bishop our opponent basically
pre-moves bishop d7 thinking that we're
going to play c3 but we're actually not
and i looked at this position a little
bit
and if we really want to take it to
black here okay there's a couple of ways
that we can play this
but the traditional idea here is to play
bishop d3 that's essentially how we
position our pieces i'll show you some
other alternatives after the game
and the point of the steinitz is that
you leave the pawn on deep where you
don't play c3 at all you just conserve
time on that move
and you make all of the normal french
moves except you don't play c3 you give
up this pawn which is captured and the
whole
system revolves around this e5 pawn and
we need to over protect it we need to
really defend it with everything that
we've got
and then eventually as you might
remember we tend to recover this pawn by
getting the knight from d2 to b3 but
before we play knight bd2 it's a good
idea to go bishop f4
and over protect the pawn so we don't
have to worry about it queen b6 and
another important property of the
steines variation is that we
like for example here i think some of
you might want to play b3 but that's a
really bad move because we want the b3
square for our knight and your instinct
here should not be to defend the pawn on
b2 what should we do instead how should
we proceed we shouldn't defend it at all
you have to realize that if black
captures on b2
we're going to be able to play rook b1
and because black is so poorly developed
opening up the b file will result in
total disaster for black we don't even
have to calculate this move it's just
intuitively going to be really really
bad so we go knight b2 anyway and then
we go knight b3 rookie one we make all
of the standard moves and eventually we
go after the d4 pawn but we're under
we're
in no rush to capture it uh it's not
poisoned per se it's not like i've
calculated the win night before okay
that's a good move
um but it doesn't fundamentally change
our approach
uh we're fine giving away this bishop so
in this system
it's actually okay to to give this
bishop away it's not ideal but it's we
can survive without the bishop
and our opponent continues to abandon
um
the king side their king side
development so
this could potentially be costly
if
if this continues for very long
what's up mr feingold okay so what did
we take with well
um
in the in the name of opening up first
of all queen takes d3 loses to bishop b5
so from that perspective we have to play
cd but in addition we would play cd
anyway because we've opened the c file
for potentially for a rook so far our
opponent i have to say is playing really
really well rook c8
okay so this is a good example of where
i wouldn't necessarily rush
to take on on d4 i mean we can play
knight b takes d4 there's nothing wrong
with that
but um
i think it might be worth contesting
contesting the c file first so let's go
rook c1 first and then this pawn on d4
is is not going anywhere we're going to
capture it at our leisure
okay 97
good stuff by our opponent
okay so now i think it's a good
opportunity to take the pawn on d4 the
question is which night do we take with
which night do we take with
oh am i loud i'm loud sorry
i leaned in by accident
sorry about that yeah sorry that was my
bad i'm sorry so
we can play knight f takes d4
or we can play knight b takes d4
so
we're going to take with the f knight
we're gonna take with the up knight
and okay there's a couple of reasons
first of all this knight on b3
can potentially jump into c5 and apply
queen side pressure
in addition i'm thinking ahead to
something that we can do on the king
side um which is that
if we drop our bishop back to e3
which i think we're going to do right
now
i think we're going to do that right now
what potential king side plan can you
indicate
that you know potentially gives us
a nice play i'm not saying we're going
to do that on the next move or anything
like that it's just something to
consider
yeah so moving the f pawn pushing f4 f5
could could potentially be
um something something to think about
so
we're pinning
i mean we're x-raying the queen right
now we have a nice position
and we've got control over the center
central squares
um yeah i'm also struggling a little bit
if knight takes c5 i think we have a
really sexy move though
if if blackface knight takes e5 we have
a really really cool discovery
can anybody indicate the square to me
gets it knight c6 we put our own knight
on c6
queen is attacked
as is the knight so knight takes e5 we
play knight cc okay queen a6
queen a6 that's an interesting move
so now i think black is threatening
knight takes c5 now we need to react to
that now i think we need to react to
that
yeah we can play f4
we can play f4
but i think the simpler thing is to is
to take on c6 i think now is the time to
take on c6
is knight c5 possible yeah knight c5 was
also possible it was an interesting move
these types of positions there is going
to be a lot of options
um you should just realize that this is
one of those like i don't know how to
define it maybe one day when i'll write
a book i'll think of different
categorizations
this is one of those positions where
it's like there's usually going to be
three or four possibilities on every
move
and they're all going to be
approximately equivalent
and it's it's these are hard positions
to play how do i decide i mean i take c6
is just simple right what's the simplest
way to deal with knight takes e5 well i
think it's just to trade knights this
also just gives us another tempo right
this gives us another tempo and our
other knight could potentially go to d4
if necessary or to c5 but it's like that
paradox about the
looks like our opponent might forfeit no
now he's reconnected
it's like that paradox about the animal
who who looks at two or like the horse
or whatever looks at two hay fields that
look identical
you know the horse is never going to
choose because
there's no reason to make one decision
over another you just eventually have to
use your intuition and make a decision
so again we have many options a2 is
hanging it's not the pawn that we have
to defend i mean we can sacrifice it if
we find something compelling
we can sacrifice it if we find something
compelling and i think i have found
something relatively compelling
you know what i like here
yeah again i mean even i'm struggling to
make a decision here we've got knight d4
knight c5
so many different moves thank you all
double chicken
but let's play it simple
let's put this other knight on d4
let's just start by bringing our knight
into the center now you might be looking
at this and saying i don't understand
what the heck i'm intending after queen
takes a2 i'll open yin on a secret i
don't actually know exactly what i want
to do after queen takes two but i'm
getting the sense that taking that pawn
with the bishop still not developed
is
this is where my intuition is firing and
saying that my intuitive neuron is just
saying okay there's just no way that
black should be able to get away with
this and i actually think that white has
a very simple
and very powerful move here i'm going to
give you a hint this move threatens to
trap the queen
this move threatens to trap black's
queen
and it also connects the rook so it's
also a
load-bearing helpful move
not b3 guys that b3 doesn't threaten to
trap the queen because rook a1 there is
still the b2 square we need to actually
defend the b2 pawn so let's think
logically why does rook a1 not trap the
queen
well it's because of queen takes b2 but
playing b3 doesn't actually cover the b2
square the problem isn't that the pawn
is hanging it's that the b2 square is
accessible to the black queen so i'm
thinking of either queen e2 or queen d2
how do we decide between those two moves
well i'm actually going to play
queen
e2
which i'm positive is not what most
people are thinking
and the reason i want to keep the queen
on e2 is because in the event that the
bishop moves away from f8 i want to be
able to reposition the queen
onto g4
in order to hit the g7 pawn does that
make sense
now here
we can win the pawn back
by playing rook a1 so that's one
possibility but we don't have to we can
also play f4 which is what i want to do
we can play up four and start going
after black's kingside trying to punish
black for not having developed his um or
her bishop
right and by the time black gets the
bishop we're already going to have our
pawn and f5 and does anybody really care
about this a2 pawn does that really
materially impact
the course of the game at least for the
next 20 moves no right
it doesn't we just push our f pawn
and and you know we enjoy our life now
this guy is is definitely you know i
would say underrated but i think we
still have a great position okay so now
what should we do well we've got options
we can play f6 but the simplest i think
is just to take on e6 and open up as
many files and avenues on the king's
side as possible and just take twice on
e6
and essentially force the rook to move
and now we've restored we've restored
material equality
okay there is an annoying move bishop d7
in this position
but already i'm thinking of various
sacrifices so what do i see when i look
at this position well one thing i notice
is that the rook on c8 is undefended
so in the event that the pawn on g7
disappears i'm looking at various
forking ideas like queen shoe for damn
i'm also looking at a really interesting
sacrifice oh man i think i see something
really cool
i think i see something really cool
i think we can just hammer away at
black's king position
this is what's called a demolition
sacrifice we sacrifice a piece
in order to demolish the pawn structure
the pawn cover around the king
and now we use our remaining pieces to
blast through now we have a really
really nice follow-up here now you might
say well is it queen g4 check no it's
not because that's hanging so one
possibility is to go queen h5 i'm
positive that some of you are thinking
of that move and i think that's a great
move but i think we have an even better
move now if you look at how you can even
access the king what are the various
avenues through which you can access the
king one of the things you might notice
is that you can do it from d4 right we
can play bishop d4
now the problem with bishop d4 is that
it's a little too slow you give black a
chance to play bishop e6 and blockade
the pawn
so
you always have to think about inverting
the move order right an idea doesn't
work you think what if i play the second
move first that leads you to e6 clearing
the path for the bishop and it's very
and now we play bishop d4 check and it's
actually just checkmate on the next move
basically
this was a very nice attack and it was a
very quick attack
right it was if if we consider f4 to be
the start of the attack it really only
took seven moves we broke open the the
center and the king side and then we
crashed through
this was nice and queen takes e6 is
literally checkmate it's not even like
it's literally made
okay cool cool that was a nice game
so again i i'm not going to delve too
deeply into the opening intricacies of
the steines variation because i've had
previous speed on games where i i spell
this out very deeply
um bishop d7 is possible and and here
again you can transpose into the
advanced french
main line with c3
but we decided to preserve the integrity
of the steinnes variation that should be
the one thing i'll point out i think
some of you might look at this and say
well aren't you afraid of c4 and the
answer is no actually c4 benefits white
and why is that true well that's true
conceptually because
because
what is the point of black's entire play
in the advanced french why is black
doing what he's doing well it's to
attack the d4 pawn
everything that black generally does in
the main line of the advance is to
attack the d4 pawn so by baiting c4
we're taking the pressure off of d4
we're investing two tempe big whoop
right bishop d3 bishop two we spent one
tempo the center is closed but now we
can fully divert our efforts to playing
on the king side now it's not as simple
as i'm describing it i don't think c4 is
actually a bad move
because black gets a lot of development
and it's this is not to suggest that
white is an easy time attacking the king
side but at the very least we don't have
to worry about the pressure on this pawn
that's the conceptual underpinning of
that
and in general i think a lot of people
are very reluctant to like go forward
and then go back but that's a totally
normal part of chess at a high level
okay so knight c6 castles
our opponent finally takes on d4
transposing into
one of the main lines so we play bishop
f4 you can also play rookie one i saw
some of you were proposing that rookie
one is a viable alternative maybe even a
better move maybe even a better move i
think i confused stuff a little bit here
because bishop f4 does allow queen b6
aiming at the pawn
so knight bd2 knight before
i'm actually seeing
one game here
22-11 against 1985 you can see
from opening explorer
so it takes
we're still following that game
and and here in that game black blade
knight e7
no it's not josh no no it's way too
early just because the center is closed
doesn't mean that both sides of the
board are closed
so now i think we made an important
decision after rook c8 so first of all
notice that we're not rushing with
knight takes d4
because that pawn's not going anywhere
and then notice which knight we took
with this knight f takes d4 decision was
very very important because we paved the
way for the pawn to to move forward
later on in the game and we keep this
knight on b3 in order to have the
capacity to jump to c5 does that make
sense so knight c6 we go bishop e3 we
hold on to the to our
d4 square
and now knight takes e5 would have been
met with knight c6 brilliant move so the
knight is protected which means that
queen takes c6 doesn't work
the queen is hanging which means that
taking with the other pieces doesn't
work
the only spot that the queen can move to
in order to keep the knight protected
is c7
but now it walks into another x-ray and
we can take on a7 winning the exchange
on c8
and winning the game shortly thereafter
no knight f3 is the stein it's e5 is
just the advance
so knight takes e5 is no good
but by the way notice that even if you
had missed this
even if you play something very
straightforward like take stakes in
queen h5 i would argue that white's
position is still practically speaking
much better just because of the
attacking potential and the fact that
black's king's side is undeveloped
so when you're 1700 you need to start
getting comfortable
i've talked about this before you need
to get comfortable with the position
concept of positional sacrifice where
you give up upon or even more to get
this long-term positional pressure you
also have to be comfortable with the
concept of
so i don't know how there's a name for
this it's where you sacrifice a pawn or
sometimes a knight in order to get a
long-term attack
right not every attack is the same some
attacks are very concentrated right like
our attack in the game
was very specific to the king side it
was a very clearly defined start and end
point
but some positions are just like and
it's the initiative i guess but it's not
exactly the initiative you can let's
call it the initiative for the sake of
brevity
so you can think of it as the initiative
this is what it means to have the
initiative it means to have this
position where you've got an attack but
the attack isn't really confined to one
part of the board you've just got
pressure everywhere maybe your opponent
has a hard time developing and judging
that those positions are good for you is
an important part of growing as a player
and not being afraid to give up upon in
order to get such a position which is
what we did here that's why i was so
easily able to sacrifice on a2 because
it's a very small price to pay for a
situation in which we're dominating on
all sides of the board
well again i think some of you like
loyalty you're
some of you ask questions like well how
do i know that a positional sacrifice is
good i don't
right any question of the form how do i
know that a move is good if i could tell
you then we'd all be magnus carlsen
another good example if if black had
played bishop c5 here who can tell me a
very powerful attacking continuation for
white
not knight b3 because a bishop takes e3
check
not knight takes c6 because this allows
a bunch of trades which is in black's
favor because black is up upon the move
is rook takes c5
now again it's a question of where do we
is there a good discovery the answer is
yes knight takes c6
and why is this so good because the
queen has to move it's a double attack
against the queen
just like a double check this means the
queen has to move and now we just start
collecting knight takes g7 and this
position is a phenomenal example of what
i'm talking about
so some of you might look at this and
say i don't understand like i'm down in
exchange what do i do panic
but
white actually should play very calmly
here you could just drop your knight
back to f5 and white is totally crushing
here
it might take five moves it might take
seven moves but one way or another white
has so many ways to approach black's
king
and black is so passive and
uncoordinated that you know for a fact
that white is overwhelming compensation
does that make sense and this should
make sense every you should be able to
look at this position and say i can see
at the very least
why white has full compensation for the
pawn
um
so that was a nice line our opponent
played bishop b4 allowing f5 and at this
point i think the attack is overwhelming
maybe bishop d7 should have been
considered by black but then we
we take on e6 and play queen g4 and
again black's position starts falling
apart here
so after castles yeah we just play f
take c6 this is a very simple attack
knight takes e6
now we get the f file
and of course seeing knight takes g7 is
you know this is an advanced tactical
idea knight g7 e6 and bishop d4 but once
i play it on the board i think everybody
understands it
i think largely finding i mean i take g7
you can find intuitively
you can play knight takes g7 without
seeing e6 i'm also positive that queen
h5 is at the very least good for white
me probably even winning
what does the eval bar say about this
position i can guarantee you that it's
already winning after knight takes g7 we
can check
we can check with the what the um
what the evolve bar says
oh it's pretty good okay so
let's see so basically we can fast
forward knight c6
d4 is good queen e2 it's saying queen h5
even is better
provoking provoking
g6 and then just sort of worming our way
into these weak dark squares
okay queen e2 is fine
f4 oh bishop d7 was best see black had
to play bishop d7 to discourage f5
bishop d but not an easy move to play
again black had to stave off the
development of the king's side
and once this happens
yeah knight g7 is good
and e6 is good but notice that queen h5
is plus eight but those are the only two
moves you have to find one of these two
moves
if you play bishop d4
after bishop e6 black is already winning
white has no continuation of the attack
yeah and this is already you can see
it's plus 11. it's totally winning and
it's basically mating
are you more comfortable sacrificing
because these players are weaker than
you will not necessarily
i'm just trying to play the position i'm
not necessarily thinking about who my
opponent is
what if queen f2
so queen f2 there's rook f8 and the bit
remember that the bishop defends the
rook so queen g3 check the king
hides on h8 and white is no follow-up
what if the king moves forward after the
bishop check so if the king moves
forward
then the ma i mean queen takes e6 check
and there's a million ways to mate but
you can i mean laddermate is fine
h3 can you for example this there's a
gazillion different mates
yes obviously i'd play the same seconds
man guys you you realize that i'm trying
to make the best move
i'm not playing the opponent i'm playing
the pieces
knight takes g7 to me is a pretty
elementary sacrifice
all right it's not like i'm playing
magnus so i'm sick of course to some
degree if i was playing magnus maybe i
would make slightly different decisions
i'm not claiming that i'm going to play
exactly the same way
but
most attacking moves and moves that i
think are best i'm going to play them
against anybody
so this is a sacrifice sacrifices are
made for different reasons and the whole
realm of sacrifice is often
misunderstood people think of it as this
one
monolith but you can sacrifice for very
different reasons
and
this sacrifice
is made in order to open up the king
it's sort of the most classic
like when you think of the word
sacrifice this is what you think of like
opening up the king so that your other
pieces can pick up the slack
what if the king don't doesn't take this
out well
technically rook f8 is the best move but
it doesn't change anything i mean we
still play e6 and we still crash through
here
hello ben
yeah this is i'm fighting an uphill
battle here
and just because it's magnet i would
beat anybody in this position this is
already completely winning
so
yeah there's nothing black can do about
it either the best move here apparently
is rook c7 lol
that's a pretty big sign that things are
things are um
going downhill for black
any questions about this before we end
because after 1976 the game is over
and again if the bishop doesn't take the
pawn
it doesn't actually change anything we
still have this mating attack
ben has a question what is the evil for
the position you showed earlier with
rook takes c5 um
so you're asking about this
the eval is it's gonna be winning for
white
it's plus three
okay knight f5 is probably not best but
it's still winning you can see it's plus
four
the best move is even e6 here just
crashing through and leaving the knight
on g7
thank you
see this is the ultimate seal of
approval
so
any questions guys
about this game anywhere
i'm just going back and forth to jog
people's memory
did you play the second karen is the
only person i probably wouldn't play it
against i'd be too scared
yeah well i've succumbed
we'll go back to
to life
okay egg protein asks an interesting
question when do you
i mean intuition versus calculation is
one of the most complicated topics in
all of chess
like deciding when you have to calculate
something and when you go for it
by definition because we're talking
about intuition there is no answer to
that if you could if you could it's a
catch-22 if you could explain why you
think something intuitively like that
literally is contradictory to the very
notion of intuition intuition literally
means you cannot explain why you think
so
so
you you can't there's no cheat code
right developing your intuition happens
in parallel to all of the other things
that you do like you just your intuition
gets better as a result of pattern
recognition and you look at more games
and you know more ideas
and it's a judgment call often like when
you just say f it and you go for it
versus when you spend five minutes
calculate
a lot of you guys are looking for this
algorithm like tell me when i need to
how do i know what to calculate versus
when to not calculate you're looking for
like a two sentence answer like this is
what needs to be the case this is how
you know but there is no such
like rule or algorithm that's what makes
this hard
so anyway sorry for the
rant but
i think this is an important topic
well i'm trying to give a rough guide
that's why i'm doing the speed run
that's why i'm
like all of this is meant to serve as a
rough guide for these kinds of questions
just as hard you guys chose a pretty
hard game to get good at
sorry
and and failed attacks are a normal part
of
chess right you're gonna have failed
attacks you're gonna look like a fool
sometimes
you're gonna sack a bunch of pieces and
nothing's going to work i've had many of
those games myself
i can probably find some if i looked
games where i just like sack everything
especially in blitz this happens
you sack a bunch of pieces and then you
over you over sacrifice
okay i'm looking right now
i had a funny game one time yeah i
sacked like two rooks
and i literally won the game because my
opponent blundered up two rooks
this is a really funny game i like i got
completely outplayed and then i started
sacrificing everything and it only
worked because i got lucky so i'll
finish with that game okay so basically
you can see i'm 2100 i'm playing in 1895
before move one
um i played sort of a french setup which
is
totally not i played very badly like i i
played dc4 which is stupid
and then he sacks the pawn actually
actually the guy played really well like
he totally outplays me
i'm much worse already because of this
terrible pawn on c6
and it just keeps getting worse i mean
look at my position all these weaknesses
and so i decide at this point all right
i'm just going to go for it
and now i start accumulating pieces on
the king side
and in this position i mean look at my
bishop um i just decide i'm going to go
nerd is style knight takes h3
gh rook takes h3
rook fe1 my opponent defends variable
work at fate blundering into another
fork
and now i give up the rook i don't even
take the knight back
and in this position
i'm down a rook and a bishop and i have
no attack like there is literally not
even a single check
i played one last try bishop b7
praying
my opponent takes on h3 so i'm down two
full rooks here and had my opponent
played king e2 i would have resigned
immediately literally i would have
extended my hand because
there is one more check and there are no
i mean i guess there's one more check
but that's it what do you think he
played here
he plays queen g2 and this actually
happened when he played it i remember
thinking like
this has to be a dream there's no way he
actually played that especially after i
played bishop b7
yeah that's a basics check
he was also very nice about it he was
just like smiling and stuff so i would
have been throwing
every electronic device that i owned
he spent he played too quickly he played
it in like two seconds
and this wasn't this was gaming 45 so i
guess technically it was rapid but it
was
rated tournament
yeah he played it quickly he played it
quickly
what electronic devices did you own in
2007 i mean a computer and a mouse
the same that i own now except a phone
wasn't that long ago
anyways guys that was just a good
example i mean not exactly on topic but
you get the point okay guys i'm gonna go
to bed i'm really really out of sorts
today sorry for the mediocre play
and uh that's about it thank you folks
thanks for uh support the support hope
you enjoyed the speedrun game thanks for
hanging out everybody later
[Music]